good morning Hank it's Friday December 9
2016 the beginning of the 10th annual
project for awesome you can head over to
projectforawesome.com now to watch the
48 hour livestream and to watch and vote
for p4a videos or head over to
projectforawesome.com / donate to donate
and get great perks from socks to signed
books so during the first half of the
project for awesome we're raising money
for Save the Children & Partners in
Health two of the most highly regarded
and efficient nonprofits working in
global health and education I want to
give you an idea of what they do and
given that this is the tenth project for
awesome I thought we could look at the
difference ten years can make like ten
years ago the renoir vu hospital in
Rwanda was extremely dilapidated and
barely functioning today it's a safe and
sanitary Hospital providing high quality
care ten years ago in Rwanda Barrera
district there were no hospitals at all
today they don't just have a hospital
they have a hospital with a Cancer
Center and a neonatal intensive care
unit and Partners in Health led the
drive to build and fund and staff both
those hospitals they also work around
the world to train and employ community
health workers like Mohammed from Sierra
Leone and tens of thousands of people
like him I'm the most sophisticated
these expensive technology in general
and it's pretty astonishing just how
effective this work has been a decade
ago almost thirteen percent of children
in Sierra Leone died before the age of
five today it's under 9% in Rwanda life
expectancy was 56 a decade ago today
it's 64 and there are similar stories
around the world in the last 10 years
the global absolute poverty rate has
fallen by more than half in 2006 18% of
the world's children were underweight
because of malnutrition today it's down
to 14% and worldwide four million fewer
children died last year than died in
2006 but there's a coldness to numbers
right like it's hard to imagine the
millions of parents who won't have to
suffer the unbearable grief of losing a
child or the tens of thousands of kids
who wouldn't have mothers if not for the
gains in maternal health in the last
decade when you here for instance that
Save the Children provides nutrition and
health care and educational
opportunities to millions of kids every
year that's not a picture I think
sometimes statistics can almost be a
barrier to empathy rather than a path to
it so let's look at one family say if
the children is very active in the
ongoing South Sudanese refugee crisis
providing education and safe spaces for
children and also trying to reunite
families who've been torn up
art by war this woman grace was
separated from her two daughters during
an attack in her community and she
hadn't seen her kids in two years in
fact she didn't even know if they'd
survived Save the Children caseworkers
were able to connect grace to her two
daughters through a database of missing
kids and reunite the family this moment
didn't end the war or end the refugee
crisis but for this one family it meant
everything whether reuniting families or
saving lives through health care and
nutrition these little successes are not
little when they're yours
of course the scope of the challenge
before us remains overwhelming as
Mohammed put it there is no easy
solution to the water social but our
support for Save the Children and
Partners in Health enables them to hire
more community health workers build more
hospitals and schools and reunite more
families and maybe a decade from now
we'll be able to look back and see how
those little successes were part of a
much larger one for the first half of
the project for awesome every dollar
donated up to $300,000 will be matched
to four dollars so you can have a huge
impact right now at project for awesome
calm slash donate and also you can get
great perks there's everything from tote
bags to commemorative pressed pennies to
the first new writing I've released in
several years during the second half of
the project for awesome will be raising
money for charities chosen by you via
your votes at projectforawesome.com so
head over there to watch and vote thank
you happy project for awesome dftba Hank
I will see you in the live stream